why don't you propose to your wife after
only dating for three months when I say
we dated for three months people tend to
believe that means that we went on like
12 dates like you went on a date a week
it was every day multiple hours a day
once we were past the first week I was
bringing her dinner every night like she
would be studying for her finals or
whatever she was a junior at UCLA event
and I bring her food we were spending
hours a day every day by a month in I
said we're never spending a Shabbat
apart so I would like sleep over at the
co-op facility where she lived this
Jewish Co-op and sleep in some other
room and then we'd spend all Shabbat
together so we're spending lots and lots
of time together